[Music]
what caused the Great Recession of 2007
and 2008 asked a dozen economists and
you'll get a dozen different answers
actually you'll get more than that
because some economists will offer two
or more reasons they'll all be right
that's because like the Great Depression
reasonable people will disagree one
expert might say it was a banking crisis
another will say no it was the housing
crisis that led to the banking crisis a
third will say but it was loose lending
standards forced on banks by government
that led to the housing crisis sometimes
I think that you could find a respected
Authority who would blame the crisis on
the snake in the Garden of Eden I
personally draw the line somewhere quite
a bit after that but I'm not exactly
sure where I do know that there is
plenty of blame to go around in this
lecture I'll be discussing how financial
institutions took some very reasonable
financial tools mortgages and
derivatives and use them improperly add
a dose of mists applied risk models
mixing a pinch of interest rate mistakes
by the Federal Reserve System and some
bad government guidance on credit policy
and you have a good start on
understanding why major institutions
failed during the Great Recession people
of all kinds claim the greedy Wall
Street types are responsible for the
crash Dean Starkman at the New Republic
wrote that the notion that American
consumers share the blame for the
mortgage crisis is a lie
Paul Malo and Matthew Padilla wrote a
book titled chain of blame how Wall
Street caused the mortgage and credit
crisis Scott Patterson a Wall Street
Journal reporter
wrote the quants how a new breed of math
whizzes conquered Wall Street and nearly
destroyed it I think we ought to make a
movie called quants gone wild quants are
highly skilled people who use
mathematical tools and models to address
financial problems such as how much your
security is worth I don't believe that
people who use quantitative finance in
their jobs at financial institutions
were a major cause of mortgage problems
or of the crisis itself I don't believe
that derivatives a financial instrument
whose price is dependent on one or more
underlying financial assets were a major
cause of the subprime problems either
after all I don't blame
I'm Stein for developing exotic theories
that made nuclear weapons possible I
will agree that a few incompetent or
misguided people at financial
institutions misused these tools and did
contribute to the financial problems
that came to light in 2007 just about
every business publication in the world
has published something about the credit
and banking problems the United States
faced the October 2007 issue of The
Economist featured a piggy bank on the
cover under the title lessons from the
credit crunch if there are lessons in a
problem then there must be an effort to
fix those problems there are also risks
of getting it wrong in April 2008 the
Economist featured a shattered piggy
bank glued together in patchwork fashion
with an artificial leg the title was
fixing finance and the subtitle was and
the risks of getting it wrong at the
time I was confident that the world
would get it wrong I did have hopes that
the world would get it more right than
wrong those hopes have not yet been
completely dashed but then the world
hasn't ended yet either there is still
time one tool that quants used and still
used to measure risk is value at risk
in the late 1980s denis whether stone
who is then the chairman of one of the
world's biggest economic institutions
JPMorgan asked this question what's the
most we can lose by tomorrow
nobody had a really good answer whether
stone was rightly troubled by that and
put his experts on the job value at risk
was the measurement tool that they
developed notice something important to
answer the question how much can we lose
you need to measure risk that is not the
same as managing risk managing risk
requires you to make a decision value at
risk just helps you generate information
to help make that decision think of a
scale it tells you how much you weigh
but it doesn't tell you if that's too
much or how to lose weight if you decide
that it is too much high value at risk
may alert managers but then what should
you make safer investments should you
raise capital so that you can handle
losses better should you shrink your
business so that you can manage it more
intensively or should you do nothing
maybe the risk level is appropriate
Value at Risk is silent it's just a tool
to generate information we don't need
the details of a Value at Risk
calculation but I will list some key
steps so that we can see where it might
go wrong first pick a time horizon
whether stone used one day but you could
use any time interval you want second
pick a probability level that's too
small to worry about if the weather
forecast calls for a thunderstorm with a
chance of hail then you might pull the
car into the garage to avoid hail damage
but I'm not going to worry about a
meteorite crashing through the garage
and damaging the car that's too unlikely
to make you reinforce the roof you can't
do business worrying about stuff like
that the Bank for International
Settlements
an international economic institution
headquartered in Basel Switzerland
said the likelihood threshold should be
a one in a hundred for one day put
differently the answer to our value at
risk calculation will be the biggest
loss that you can expect to see on 99
days out of 100 after you calculate your
value at risk then you'll have an answer
the next time the boss asks you what's
the most we can lose by tomorrow you the
quantum made the calculation could
answer if we rule out events that you
said are too rare to worry about then
the most we can lose is let's say 12% in
one day that's far from a perfect answer
but it's way better than nothing at this
point if you've done your job right
which includes explaining where you had
to cut corners or assume something to
make the problem tractable then I say
you're off the hook if something goes
wrong it's not your job to say whether
that's too much or too little risk and
it's not your job to decide what to do
if somebody decides this risk level is
inappropriate I did say that it's your
duty to explain the assumptions you made
and the corners you had to cut to list a
few you need to pick a distribution of
losses maybe you use the normal
distribution for example that
bell-shaped curve we've all seen so
often you also assume that the
distribution wouldn't change much over
time that's flatly not true sometimes
the world is riskier than other times I
understand that you have to make
reasonable assumptions to get an answer
the red flag is if management doesn't
adjust for the riskier times in king of
the north a historical fantasy novel by
Harry Turtledove
Geron the Fox says if you went through
Rapids in a canoe and came out the other
side alive and unhurt you hadn't
manipulated them you just survived
you forgot the difference at your peril
forgetting this difference is the second
place where quants and management go
wild but let's not be too hard on them
we've all made this mistake we've all
gunned our cars
to make a yellow light but we're here we
survived
surviving doesn't make us right we must
admit that we are no different from the
quants and those who rely on them we
can't assume that because we got through
the rapids every time so far that we'll
always get through them because an event
hasn't happened doesn't apply it'll
never happen that's the famous
Black Swan problem until the late 17th
century Europeans hadn't seen Black Swan
but it was wrong to conclude that they
didn't exist in fact it turned out they
were rather common in Western Australia
the very rarity of these extreme events
makes it nearly impossible to gauge
their true likelihood suppose you'd
expect something to happen once in a
hundred years now suppose it doesn't
happen at all in a hundred years would
you revise your expectations the problem
is intractable if we could go back
another hundred years then we'd only get
one more data point for a one in a
hundred event and even then would you be
willing to assume that nothing important
for your estimate changed during those
two hundred years one of my favourite
Dilbert cartoons illustrates the second
problem it's prehistoric Dilbert
prehistoric Dilbert is holding a hammer
next to a round stone a reptilian
dogbert asks what is it
prehistoric Dilbert replies I call it
the wheel the final panel shows the two
trying to toast marshmallows over the
wheel the wheel is in fact a very good
invention using it to cook your food is
a bad application this good invention is
bad for that purpose on Wall Street
people refer to model risk even if the
model is right it might be inappropriate
for this purpose one of the greatest
financial innovations in the 20th
century is the mortgage pool banks and
other financial institutions throw a
bunch of more
into a pot and then sell claims on its
earnings it's like a mutual fund for
mortgages that's a great idea
homebuyers get better access to loans
banks can manage their risk by selling
some or all their loans and investors
get access to a new diversified
investment tool with nice
characteristics so what's the problem
we've learned that the correlation among
loans in mortgage pools how their values
move together were higher than expected
meaning that the risk of that portfolio
was higher than expected
they aren't nearly as diversified as
people thought lots of institutions lost
lots of money when credit problems
surfaced bad inputs were another problem
Yale University economist Robert Shiller
a Nobel laureate and expert on housing
prices has constructed an index of US
housing prices back to 1890 he put
everything in constant dollars to take
out the effects of inflation what he
found might surprise you you'd expect
prices to wiggle around up and down and
you'd be right you'd expect the Downs to
be worse during recessions and Wars and
you'd be right again what do you think
the average annual real return on
housing in the United States was from
1890 through 1996 the annual real return
was about 1/10 of 1% that's all now
pretend that you are a manager of a
mortgage lending institution what would
you think if I told you that during the
next 10 years real housing prices would
double that implies an annual return of
60 or 70 times more than it was during
the previous hundred years what would
you think at the end of those 10 years
you might think wow this is a great time
to be a mortgage lender I'm making a
fortune nobody defaults on a house
already worth twice as much as he paid
for it
especially if it's going higher yet
that's a perfectly natural reaction it's
been spot-on for 10 years and counting
but I hope that you would ask yourself
what is happening here is this normal
do I really know as much as I think I
know I hope you would say this is a good
time to re-evaluate my tools and methods
there was also plenty of warning that
defaults on mortgages were becoming a
major problem delinquency rates on some
prime mortgages by age and date of
origination as of summer of 2008 make
that plain for loans made in 2003
delinquency rates after 18 months or a
bit over 5% for 2005 it was about 10%
for 2006 it was over 20% for 2007 it was
at least 25% hindsight is 20/20 but it's
hard to believe that lenders couldn't
have seen this coming these numbers
aren't a fancy high-tech math tool used
by sophisticated financial institutions
the key points here are first there was
plenty of warning and second no risk
measurement tool for stalls problems if
you ignore the signals it tends UBS AG
is a huge international Swiss financial
services company with headquarters in
Zurich and Basel UBS said Value at Risk
was part of the reason it lost 38
billion dollars from January 2007 to
April 2008 UBS portion post-mortem said
that it had become overconfident
although risk monitors were flashing do
you remember that the Bank for
International Settlements said
institutions should use a one in a
hundred day as their risk threshold USB
had 16 exceptions meaning their actual
losses exceeded their value at risk
threshold in one month
to summarize UBS suffered sixteen one in
a hundred days out of 21 or 22 trading
days in a month such an exception should
happen at most three times per year
UBS is risk model with screening I am
not appropriate for this period yet this
huge international economic institution
failed to react to evidence that its
assets were riskier than it had thought
or that the markets volatility had
increased something had gone dreadfully
wrong no risk measurement or management
tool will work if you ignore it big
international financial institutions
like UBS can add value if they do it
right though one example is transparency
here's an illustration of how that can
matter you've all seen the carnival game
in which the performer shuffles a ball
around and you guess which cup hides the
ball assuming I use three cups and that
the prize for guessing correctly is
three dollars and if you and I agree
that my skill was shuffling is equal to
your skill with tracking my sleight of
hand then the fair price to play is a
dollar you'll lose two out of three on
average but winning the third one makes
us even
but even that assumes were right about
your skill matching mind there's
uncertainty about both the fair price
and the outcome
we'd have winners and losers and people
would be speculating on their skill and
borrowing money to double their bets and
so forth
people might worry that losers who might
have borrowed money won't be able to pay
up that's a fair description of what
happens in mortgage markets that's a
messy situation that could become
dangerous but watch how simple this gets
with just one small change in Steven
passes his comic strip pearls before
swine pig the simpleton among the
characters wants to bet ten dollars in
this game of shuffling the ball under
the cups goat the brainy philosopher
notices that the cups are
as parent pig responds well that's why I
mix them around that's funny because
it's so incredibly stupid
if the cups are transparent then go will
correct guess correctly every time we've
eliminated the risk we know the outcome
that's bad for pig but it's good for
society that's because in a competitive
market instead of a carnival the cost of
playing this game would rise from one
dollar to reflect the one-in-three
chance of winning to three dollars which
is a guaranteed payout furthermore
there's no longer any reason to
speculate there's no reason to borrow
money to increase your bets transparency
is a really good way to improve asset
pricing increasing transparency in the
mortgage market works exactly the same
way big institutions can make securities
easier to value suppose that I've found
an unknown number of pennies and I offer
them for sale how much will you pay for
them go ahead think of a number it's
hard to be sure isn't it
permit me the financial institution to
perform some financial engineering magic
I'll just put those pennies in one of
those coin rolls and presto it's easy of
package the pennies so that they're
easier to value sometimes people want
something that doesn't exist if that's
the case then you can make a lot of
money if you can find a cheap way to
give them what they want one of the most
successful examples of that is the
collateralized mortgage obligation or
CMO for short here's the situation many
financial institutions are good at
arranging mortgages but aren't well
suited to hold them until they're paid
off the solution is to make or originate
the mortgage then sell it to some other
institution that is better able to hold
it for longer periods this is very
common in fact we know that investors
want safe predictable investments and
will pay more for them the institution
that originates the loan one
to get the highest price it can
mortgages are kind of safe but because
people sometimes pay off their mortgages
early they aren't as predictable as we'd
like have people invested in mortgages
that will last for thirty years or for
five years it's hard to tell how can we
solve these problems first we get
ourselves a container then we throw a
bunch of mortgages into the container
next we poke a hole in the bottom of the
container and put another one underneath
it let's call that bucket tranche a will
let the cash from the mortgages in the
container at the top flow out into
tranche a will poke a hole in the side
of tranche a - so that when it gets
filled up the cash begins to overflow
into another bucket below that that's
tranche B we can have tranches C and D
or however many we'd like this
dramatically reduces maturity variation
if you invested in tranche a then you're
going to be repaid soon and you have
almost no risk the further down you go
the more risk that there won't be enough
cash to repay you buyers of tranches B
and C earn higher interest rates to
compensate for the risk they take with
the longer maturities this is wonderful
the institution has taken a pile of
risky mortgages with uncertain maturity
and transform them into securities the
tranches with relatively predictable
cash flows tailored just for you by
whichever tranche you like institutions
have used this basic idea to transform
many risky securities into new ones some
have dozens of tranches each CMO or
similar structure can have different
sized tranches still CMOS have generally
worked well since they were introduced
in 1983 how can these financial
instruments get institutions in trouble
in the novel the moon is a harsh
mistress by Robert Heinlein professor
bernardo de la Paz says like fire
infusion government is a dangerous
servant and a terrible master he could
have been describing financial
engineering - I hope I've convinced you
that value at risk and other
quantitative tools in and of themselves
weren't the problem and that instead
ignoring the signals from these risk
measurement approaches was the problem I
hope that you understand some of the
good things that financial engineering
can do now we'll look a little bit
deeper to see if we can understand why
the models were flashing red and how
some financial innovations were misused
which eventually topped toppled
financial institutions I'll argue that
risk managers of major economic
institutions misused some financial
models and didn't fully appreciate some
risks the Federal Reserve System made
some mistakes to add some bad regulatory
policy and you have at least a start for
why we experienced the Great Recession
of 2007 and 2008 the first source of
trouble is easy money I stand with most
economists who believe in hindsight the
Federal Reserve kept rates too low for
too long from about 2002 through 2006
nothing is perfect but the Taylor rule
has been a quite effective tool for
monetary policy named for its developer
John Taylor of Stanford University the
Taylor rule tells policy makers what the
federal funds rate should be using
current inflation and the relationship
of gross domestic product to its long
term trend the Fed did a rather good job
of applying the Taylor rule until about
2001 not so good after that the Fed held
rates too low relative to the Taylor
rule from 2002 through 2006 had the Fed
followed the Taylor rule rates would
have begun to rise in 2002 rather than
2004 the increases in rates also would
have been more gradual if the Taylor
rule had been followed
I believe that some of the credit
problems traced to rates being too low
for too long and the subsequent increase
being too sudden that easy money
contributed to a second problem lacks
underwriting standards in the years
before the crisis this would count as a
performing loan say I can't make the
payment but have home equity the lender
says oh no problem I'll just roll it
into the principal that makes sense if
housing prices rise or if it's a
temporary problem a big medical expense
for example but it's not a performing
loan in the sense of the word that most
people would think if we include these
loans as performing then this would make
a loan portfolio look safer than it
really is a performing loan has no
missed payments in the most recent 90
days that makes sense
but did you know that if the mortgage
holder sells the loan then the clock
resets yes on say day 25 I sell your
mortgage to an investor the clock resets
to zero that sounds fishy to me a
performing loan suggests that someone is
making payments in this case you're not
the federal government in my view took
an especially pernicious role in the
decline in standards my example is the
Boston Fed the president of the Boston
Fed wrote the Federal Reserve Bank of
Boston wants to be helpful to lenders as
they work to close the mortgage gap
higher rejection rates for minorities
for this publication we have gathered
recommendations on best practices from
lending institutions and consumer groups
I didn't even have to insert the quotes
around best practice to highlight the
irony the Boston Fed did that for me why
would a consumer group have knowledge
about bank lending practices or even be
unbiased what were these best practices
in closing the gap a guide to equal
opportunity lending you'll
these nuggets from the Boston Fed credit
history lack of credit history should
not be seen as a negative factor down
payment and closing costs lenders may
wish to allow loans from relatives
nonprofit organizations or municipal
agencies to cover part of these costs
sources of income Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac will accept the following as valid
income sources over time and part-time
work second jobs including seasonal work
and unemployment benefits the credit
history rule asks us to pretend that two
individuals who are identical except
that one has a credit history and one
does not really are identical in every
relevant way I doubt that's true the
downpayment rule mixes legitimate
capital like a bank balance with
questionable examples of capital for
example loans from builders the sources
of income rule is a mixture of the
reasonable and the unreasonable it's a
mistake to include temporary sources of
income when a mortgage is long-lived the
bottom line is that these best practices
lead to too much debt backed by too
little income not to worry though you
see the Boston Fed didn't make these
best practices mandatory they were
voluntary birthday gifts are voluntary
too in another pearls before swine Ling
Ling and ping ping the two giant pandas
have a conversation ping ping the female
says it's my birthday today ping ping
what says ping ping I say it's my
birthday so in the final panel Pig says
why do you think the zoo has so much
trouble getting Ling Ling to mate with
ping ping
who knows says goat the Boston Fed even
added and
threat did you know failure to comply
with the Equal Credit Opportunity Act or
regulation B can subject a financial
institution to civil liability for
actual and punitive damages in
individual or class actions this isn't
based on sound economic policy let me
dramatically oversimplify Charles
Calomiris and Steve Haber's book the
fragile by design the political origins
of banking crises and scarce credit I
call it the politicians credo don't give
money directly to your friends instead
have banks give money to your friends
then bail out the banks in this case
politicians would prefer not to give
money directly to people with bad credit
instead they encourage banks to make
loans to people with bad credit at below
market rates then if the loans go bad
they bail out the banks with programs
like the troubled asset relief program
more than eight years before the
mortgage crash fyodor day a professor of
management at the University of Texas at
Dallas and Stanley B wits and economics
professor there predicted the result
they wrote after the warm and fuzzy glow
of flexible underwriting standards has
worn off we are likely to find that we
are merely encouraging banks to make
unsound loans if this is the case
current policy will not have helped its
intended beneficiaries if in future
years
they are dispossessed from their homes
due to an inability to make their
mortgage payments it will be ironic and
unfortunate if minority applicants wind
up paying a very heavy price for a
misguided policy remember experts will
give you dozens of causes for the Great
Recession and most of them make some
sense I hope I've convinced you that
financial engineering by itself isn't
bad but
that risk managers of major economic
institutions did misuse some of them mix
in a - a Federal Reserve air and a dose
of bad regulatory policy and you have a
recipe for a good part of the reasons
for the Great Recession of 2007 and 2008